what's up fool what's up fool podcasts
what's up fool
we're back after so long in the studio
we rode through a toy right here with a
bad back what's happening man
at least our hairs Partha better akiro
practie hey we'll do it chiropractors hi
hon the doctor breaker I guess only your
doctor only if you give up medicine
right psychiatrist is a doctor yeah
psychologist however people get a
doctorate in education because of
doctors you're a doctor and educational
they should because doctors listen
because doctor of Education Williams
come here please somebody heard you on
your mom's house already what's up fool
oh man forgot to tell you bro
the to test recap what happened that day
I went to the HBO re the HBO party Amy
you said something about it but then let
that stay here I don't think I'll write
into the Simmons Family the Russell
Simmons family no gene Simmons Nick
Stevens the wife and the wife shattered
tweed so I want to see what's up to them
but I hang out I want to see gene see
with hair like like there's no way that
focus starts here with nobody brother
just not that wig off is it a week it's
something wrong and then expunged it out
though don't they
I don't know man he's I grabbed a hair
that's off the end of the table a man
who was tall man and his son is talking
here what do you go to hell yeah well at
these things many here free everything
there was like a section where they'll
give free makeup and we'll make up
artist fix you know people because
they're the next the next place is free
photos yeah like that photo booth you
know the gang of cookies brought like
good ass cookies the best the best good
tiny miniature cakes and there were all
like companies like they want us they
want to get known so they're like
promoting their brand giving up little
pound cakes bro the little frosted cakes
then you go down and there's a bunch of
food bro like shrine rib only the best
lobster
yeah good shave wrap but did you see
like celebrities they man nobody likes
free [ __ ] like rich people bro
oh you think okay there were all your
Chi bro and cheap oh man when we went to
the Playboy Mansion a few years ago and
you did that like charity ball thing
this woman and her son this woman was
like 60 70 something and her son was
like mid-30s look you know edgy guy -
okay they're both stealing the
centerpieces after they're like they're
not going to use them again and they're
taking them home they're like flower
arrangements like elaborate flower
arrangements they were taken home the
next door next door and the next door
yeah they live in the neighborhood so
they've been doing this for years
yeah taking a centerpieces home like
there were these people with freshly
made Botox bro in a plastic surgery
trying to chew or [ __ ] a slider bro meat
to another side of their mouth so your
comedian has her life like some of these
people are filthy filthy rich but they
can't afford a sandwich bro some of that
because other monies paying for that
house their lifestyle bro there's no
more there's no more money for food
because you got all these people you
think you were to fire some of y'all
gotta fire one me
bro in order to eat in order to eat good
but thinking about what they go to leave
these British people have these parties
bro I think just so they could just feed
each other
just nobody well you have millions of
dollars but you're paid thirty five
thousand dollars a month for a gardening
all this money so you don't know food we
need to go out so the rich people but
they probably have these expensive
parties so they couldn't all eat good at
one time and like a Cordina for for rich
people
okay next week you're gonna have a big
extravagant meal and we're gonna get
your house condi now this is a car show
ya bro college right now what's up boo
so do I saw behind him and I said gene
Simmons Nick Saban's Shannon Tweed he
has a little plastic surgery he was a
larger I get something for free too bro
cupcakes eats cupcakes I started like
walking around bright I saw most of the
cast of the insecure took some horrible
pictures with them didn't even post it
up no chance to ask for a second one
damn I said what you Lewis short and
kind of out of it seemed like just
seemed a little like I think it was
overwhelmed with the whole party no he
was just like it was a lot going on
around his yeah just people a lot of
people my favorite vegan food if you're
asking is right now man impossible
burger and fat burger or you could get a
man um and White Castle also at the
Cheesecake Factory has a vegan Cobb
salad and they have the impossible
burger I would get it without the cream
and the butter but do you know what man
is still good burgers delicious cheese
wheel ordered that the first night
house bombed what how did you [ __ ] up
your back first about that you showed up
bro like you like you internal like like
your back is messed up bro and your back
look like you're walking like like all
day eternal avoid bumping into people
like I told you initially dude I was
just out back on this like hillside and
both my feet were straight and then like
the dirt slip and one of my legs went
down and I just felt a little and then
like right after that I felt like inside
in the middle of my body in my wasted
like my back was like spasm II and did
like I had to grab onto something or
also just gonna like collapse into pain
and then I just had to come out of there
all like walking like Frankenstein
[ __ ] kill dog you're like you could've
hit me in the back with the bat and I
still wouldn't have felt that I would
have felt been feeling the initial pain
and that hasn't happened in like [ __ ]
seven years dude don't happen my
three-times know when I fell off the
ladder that was just a bruise on the
side of my back this will say a fat word
problem I don't know bro is your mom a
fat boy got a word doc some more drugs
you go Farley the when you did he does
do DDP yoga right DDP yoga no that's uh
what is that for like family yogurty oh
no I do regular yoga Diamond Dallas Page
wrestler he has a yoga line yeah your
money gets when your pockets gonna have
your bro your back gives out how about
Mario saying I thought all the money's
in the clouds above I rose Danny you too
though so here our fight the other
[ __ ] up back to so but that was funny
will you said that out went to the
chiropractor
oh the chiropractor said listen man you
know what okay he's all he just told me
is all I can put you back in and I can
align you but you got to do the other
half I can't do both
press 1 if you shopped in a husky I
don't or so though I knew it works
you're fat
I have a long torso no danger though dog
give it in her face and [ __ ] like oh but
my I have a long torso so my body is in
the bottom but you can't tie up your
pants no I can't pick up my I can put my
pants on the fall back down but I can't
I have a short or long torso so an
extra-large
it's always gonna look small on me like
this how many Long's
like Martine bro my dad's back is longer
than my team will hear the [ __ ] shark
shark body go a little fins at feet you
got a strong upper back hey but you know
what my dad said four more like I said
I'm surprised your [ __ ] stomach
hasn't yank your [ __ ] spine so much
that she hasn't snapped what happened oh
by the way better if you that I listen
you're listening right now I was on your
mom's house and I was on Tiger Bali no
sleep till Brooklyn are these shows oh I
was saying that when you guys came back
on Monday and you were coming up the
driveway you went to put something in
your car and then you're coming up the
driveway
I kind of was looking out of the garage
and cuz I thought you were coming back
but you're taking a long time and you
stood there like you look like you're
frozen in the robot and then you moved
again you started up again this is what
happens dude like if I sit for a while
even like an hour when I get up it's
like it takes I have to like warm up
dude like and like this fool like you
know after a while he forgets it I don't
have my backing in [ __ ] up and he
starts walking but like fast on my
eighth or were you at will you're
gripping a pillar dog and that's the
thing is it's not the back that's [ __ ]
up it's a muscle they got [ __ ] up from
yeah you know like be like near the your
sciatic yeah area so that's your pinches
or wherever the [ __ ] that's what
it's because I went one time that what
time it happened five years ago
Oh to the doctor I thought something was
bad and then a full look at your spines
fine fine stop eating but I sigh dude
I'm not funny how about those fools in
there like [ __ ] 300 400 pounds dog
whines [ __ ] [ __ ] break it is there
they have knee and back problem solid
food like I'm pretty sure bro like it
would tire bang those people I try right
now those people you're talking about
if you lift up their sweats or you lift
up and [ __ ] your but their pants and you
[ __ ] you put down their socks go [ __ ]
the purple a speedrun with a purple hat
legs bro that doesn't even go down blood
goes no more gonna get those sauce bro
at Walgreens bro for fat people
circulatory problems start yeah
compression socks my sons are tight now
when you went to where the chiropractor
and what did that guy say when that
bigger fatter douche - walked out before
you he told me though you don't want to
be like that guy like nobody ever says
they're like like somebody wants to be
you wanna be like he's all I want to
help you out bro cause he's all oh the
other guy about three years old shut the
[ __ ] up yeah he look like a big old tow
truck I never really look it already has
[ __ ] prune feet fool look like he
weighs 500 pounds dog came out of the
come out of the door sideways what was
wrong with him though his problems yeah
bashful said it was his upper back in
his [ __ ] his um his dies and that dis
aligns him but he's on its cuz the
waitress and when that fool was walking
he wasn't walking like we walk like this
he's walking to the side that's why my
friend Pete was 500 pounds he waddled do
go home and think about it or they
Saturday to go straight to a fast-food
7-eleven get a big hot dog in a soda
okay seven Rico yes we had a pitch
meeting yesterday we had a pitch meeting
this morning and we have a pitch meeting
this afternoon and we will see those are
all the top three networks so cross your
fingers everybody like a candle whatever
you do yeah we picked up we pitched our
sitcom listen I with I'm a bee with a
CNBC yesterday anyway well maybe there
was a BC and they were NBC CBS CBS and
we don't know about Fox so that we don't
even know that show that we don't even
know nothing about Fox yeah we don't
know anything so we'll see you sugar
decompression table well that's the
thing you lie on that in that one video
where you go back like that all the one
that's over here okay oh is that here oh
yeah that was here I forgot I thought
that was good for you wanna see if I can
hang yeah I don't think you're gonna
make it dude no no and then you you look
down we're gonna play don't you see you
got that broken plane remember
oh the one in the middle seat yeah I've
never even seen that before I was like
this plane it kept you in the seat so
huh they're six volunteers to get a
measly 300 dollars yeah it was funny
though how many people went for it
though I was surprised usually some
people don't go for it so Steve man the
people don't go further people like me
because they know because I know how
hard it's gonna get with your bugs back
they're gonna make it as hard as
possible for me to get those 200 bucks
back
casino all again do I get 200 bucks back
they gotta give me a voucher for the
flight I miss mm-hmm it's nice to take
it you gotta fight for not gonna be on
standby a nice flight you're not
guaranteed to be on the next plane you
just did that
do they really just say that that you're
not Garrett what do you mean well the
next player to be for two broads you
know what it depends on your class that
you not it's not it's not first class
second class whatever buy your ticket
it's where you buy your ticket if you
buy a discount ticket on like orbit or
whatever through some sort of service
you're given like a class why ticket if
you'll see like a class on a class J
whatever that's really like how you
purchase your - you went through the
airlines website you take more precedent
and of course
over there you take priority or you and
of course if you're like a high level
like Ruby or whatever of your status
over premier then of course that helps
as well you don't get bumped off a
flight but we got kicked off a flight at
one time because the plane that came in
was 30 seats too small for the people
who had tickets no they didn't know it
until it got there and we all got
vouchers everybody was an [ __ ] and I
got all these extra pouches and I flew
my family did you know come see me on
graduation and all this stuff and but
yeah it was like 30 people smaller that
plane so all the people who had that Y
class got bumped for that little slight
inconvenience it was 270 final credit
yeah Oh Toby Center the whole flight oh
I got problems I don't even think about
the problems you had we were relieved I
was out there for that oh they had two
wine bottles this was for the little
complain they were too louder yeah some
guys I wish guy that dude right in front
of Toby that old man but then look they
sort of talk to you yeah then I was like
come on tell this is the flight from
Nyack to no to LAX to Knight lower life
and I'm all you know I'm all Toby what
do people act like they're on their own
private jets oh man you gotta stop I'm
all seriously he's trying to shush us
get some headphones or you guys all in
coach yeah yeah I wasn't the most about
with and it was three of us yeah but
Toby said so we got ended up kid I don't
know why we got free drinks but I guess
we're premier class or something yeah so
uh they're all okay I get a little want
cuz I'm I want a wine this was all I'm
whining tell me [ __ ] let me breath this
brother some wine Arliss we can unwind
the chick and uh okay and I was like
cool and they're all uh you get your
drink for free I'm alright wait a minute
how about you give me another one of
those little bottles and give him
another one that way you'll have to come
back that's when the five ten that makes
a middle mental note right there is
deserving this fruit here and there come
back
so then this one monkey flight attendant
I guess he's been in that predicament
before this [ __ ] says [ __ ] those
two little bottles Toby Peter himself
check the bottles goddamn bug you guys
drink come on dogs like man I got we get
there round we get - well - Nayak and
it's really their madness or anything it
looks like the town where the Goonies
live yeah
like oh oh like the beginning of every
day you hear that noise that that song
for the Scooby Doo don't-don't-don't the
fog rolls in there's a boat passing by
every morning and then there's a freeway
like The Goonies
I don't get to see the tower to the last
day but it was beautiful when I went
down if they have a bookstore with like
that people actually live on top of it
you know hit a fatass ball see some
coffee and then chitchat like Kramer
down there for five hours and lie and
they go back upstairs bro yeah it was
cozy over there
it was cool bad and bladder right there
but that wasn't the but I'll get to you
they just continental breakfast nothing
like that continent how are you gonna
give you bagels with no toaster dog yo
no cream cheese
who gonna eat it like that oh it's hard
and what's the hot water ran out that
was there brother
so you're a tea drinker sorry I beg your
pardon
just one cup of tea please
so I passed out I was tired I'm doing
the show man I did the comedy show
Beverly I'm sure I did the show on now
I'm Saturday night and I'm doing you
know I'm doing my regular bits I'm doing
drug addiction jokes you know cocaine
cocaine there's and have a fat stomach
I really can't Bank the girl starts
packing my own stomach and that came
hearing a woman saying you need help you
need help you need help and I thought
this woman is heckling me right like
maybe I do need help because of cocaine
addiction but it's just a joke I'm
talking about but he said you need help
you need help then we need orange juice
we need always juice that's what the
[ __ ] this lady's dying in the back she's
having a diabetic attack no she really
is dying so I called up I don't know
what to do man I got doing comedy shows
deal and it goes yeah hey Jennifer I
know there's somebody's taking a back
but we focus on a person who's up here
alive and up I just two people that had
there's a doctor here I'm the only one
that was with says everybody like a
robotic case everybody is to go to grow
well [ __ ] happens see who the followers
are run away run away nobody no body was
trying to help I'm the only one was
caught with a conscience people are
trying to focus on the show but most of
the people just staring staring and
there's people who are gonna get it away
I know it happens it's our wacky like
always happening like to get in the way
a guy that walks up to like Rick from
[ __ ] to the trailer park boy with a
drink over there and what's the fur you
do bros a drink
I've got a fight broke out me too I
thought a little bit of advice like why
would people fight at the show I thought
like these Latinos are going out like
Colombians reporter Ricans or something
I don't know dawg people are telling in
the back so I don't know what's going on
you're right I did to you with a fight I
was like cuz something drop like a glass
drop there's some like tables move I've
put her slappy that orange you just lit
up and they huh
so I pretty sure
I don't know what's going on so I said
it's your doctor in this place it's real
doctor in this place then this lady said
I'm a doctor wow you like my comedy cuz
I was surprised that the doctor of a
comedy show - so good oh yeah she didn't
help so she was overheard three
girlfriends
I guess there are doctors there doing
nothing and they come back so that they
turn the lights on that makes it real
bad for comedy the lights are now
everybody looking over there
are there other sheeps so they take the
lady out and then I got do my comedy
again bro it's weird bro I don't know I
guess you gotta have over 10,000 shows
to be able to do this oh good
you have to keep it going what are you
alright [ __ ] it hang on let's tend to
this lady if you're hosting you were
about the next [ __ ] alright dude
it's like what are you gonna do man and
then like dude we're just chaotic and
then like calm down but like it took him
a long time to get the lady to the front
of the showroom oh you saw that get her
out yeah we're there cuz when they went
down I will see if they kill her
yeah well they just walked out with her
like holding the bottoms of her [ __ ]
arms like her are people I can't help it
around and then her friends were humping
around - she was with five four other
women I think two of them were relatives
and two of them were friends other when
all those days I stayed man look at her
bad paternity dies you're gonna be
without paint look at the bill but uh
yeah man it was like [ __ ] crazy and
it's like I don't think it's those
people that go out a lot - so okay it
was like they were at the oh dear the
young generations of the little big
forehead family they were loaded - some
of them yeah two of them were buzzed off
she was children - oh so I'm up there
bro and I said I told the audience that
you know what of the office where Kevin
is waiting to have cancer and mine is
Michael's birthday hit it all planned
out I felt like Michael right now
we're outside I can't believe you're
selling merch and they're still treating
her behind you bro
oh dude like we have a word we had the
merch it was a couch and they sat her
down right there and she's always you
know she's like slowly getting back to
normal and [ __ ] and then this was I'll
give her a shirt cool
and then she [ __ ] after the while
they took pictures with this fool and
[ __ ] and then I laid all my friends have
shirts - oh dude only makes one just ask
for more when somebody gives you
something
thank you for more I just feel like you
give a [ __ ] away you give somebody a bug
see at least some of those shirts are
$10 yeah I mean there was loss of profit
right I mean the ones fine ones very
nice you could ask for like four more go
get some from my homeboy so bad she dyed
it well I told her I told her she told
me that could I get one for my friends
and they're all waiting bro and I said I
don't know man I didn't really die she
found out how much the bill was brought
twenty five hundo ought to go to dia
they found out the how much it cost for
the ambulance to take her to the
hospital so did she not she went home
she didn't have to pay for them to just
come out they don't come out every
especially in New York the attacks
everything dude so yeah it's not free
free free but you know but when she
found out about how much it was to go to
the doctor she was like bah bah fine
yeah it took her walls too but I think
she was all laughing it leaving dogs I
would have never even done on the Levi
be she's that person a group huh I think
so too
she's like that woman to try that their
homegirl are you party with always
passes out so you're like party with
weekend at Bernie's so everybody has
their that one friend that I gotcha that
girlfriend I get too drunk but she's not
really a [ __ ] she just works too hard
bro puts it on hard $15 a week bro at a
office job or she has a good job and
she's hitting her with was Comcast dawg
don't work yeah these chicks don't have
a regular job hours a day I have a
meeting to go to our Monday so she said
when I gets real [ __ ] up
she got [ __ ] up a happy hour she got
[ __ ] up waiting for these [ __ ] to
get ready too much overtime she's
[ __ ] - it's too [ __ ] important bro
she has [ __ ] to do so that putting her
broker but she she paid for everybody
and she goes you know what I [ __ ] up
the show let's give them some dessert
like I like the large bro he passes off
fast but that was a neat dog the second
show had another oh my god the second
show man I keep going down I said I said
screw this man somebody gave ain't a
little little brown skis and I'm on
stage man chillin and then I see a like
a flickering like the one on the right
and the left hand side of me and in
front of me and in the corners like
flickering like barely going down like
but you knew something was wrong I knew
something wrong
let us bigger lies bigger lies that's
okay I don't make a joke about this okay
ladies and gentlemen I had a brownie
earlier he told me you are seeing lights
flickering - then it was I laughing yeah
and then rah rah rah
everybody please some people were like
wait for everybody else will even
they'll leave - but they didn't but also
it also felt like building the office -
when Michael's trying to close that
speech out and on that boat if you try
get everybody's attention
the boat is sinking and they [ __ ] old
man first to the jump on a walk jump
into the water whoo Creed
I love greed I don't want I brains tight
I don't work tonight
he showed up and he said the cops were
there and I put took off bro
he come into work hey how about that
what time were left spiked up is here
and trying to come back
how about were fairly hired new people
and enables breastfeeding and it Jim
lips over here
that he looks over at creep we're way
ahead of you started eating a yogurt
next to her looking at her bro repeat
he's a good ass character or not you
like butters in Southport Oh Christopher
Sachi was once a [ __ ] it was another
thank you bro I thank you for getting a
free t-shirt date you bro
no he wants to think Rodrigo for the
free shirt welcome and thanks for your
birthday shout out to him but that's the
third message man like your girl free
t-shirt oh yeah you should be happy
don't you our friends are the only fact
that what a shout-out for getting a free
t-shirt shout out well so loud no
Clarissa shall eh miss the Schomburg
show how was it it was good bro 2008
well so Christopher's bark dead hateful
that's the one you say happy birthday to
so then the alarm went off right yeah
and it got normal again and then it pops
up again dude it pops it again because
there's something there was a fire at
[ __ ] Popeyes like a grease fire a
grease fire someone probably what any
burning so the most you do right
somebody did if you're gonna get fired
are you a hate hate this job up you just
click it on I would have clicked it I
will [ __ ] put the whole floor full of
oil down like teenagers messing around
fry and stuff they shouldn't have been
frying we always caught fires doing that
stuff working in fast food you ever play
around
no I worked at a restaurant though
everything I see Noah and Rosie oh she
just is different a little more
professional I guess Union job you need
job that we don't mess around we get
paid there are teenagers messing around
I know they got a grease burn all over
my arm I still have a scar from it but
it's light no no Beall aye I dropped it
I worked at pretzel fest and I I worked
at pretzel fest and I was making a corn
dog corn dog for somebody and the corn
dog slipped off the the stick and into
the batter and
flashed on my arm right there and then I
had to call my boss and ask if I could
go and he was so I know now he was
afraid of like a worker's comp claim and
he was like trying to basically like
steer meet or talk okay so you're
choosing to go home or something you're
okay and I was like yeah and he's like
okay like he wanted to make me say it
like that I was okay you know and I
didn't get it at that time it was 16
sunlight without a twisted her ankle
also the Republic I'm gonna make sure
you the lab wah sounds good I go down
right now let it cool down first but
I've seen a corridor as big as a
microphone and a fair one time I don't
like him like that big dog that kind of
gross dog really feel like I'm small I
like more breading they don't say like
you know there's too much food or what I
think I don't want to take a bite out of
something that big I do I had a big-ass
banana today at Starbucks house I
thought that was too much food because
food well all right have you ever been
to Vegas it's not so fun
okay I worked in fret so fest and her
best friend worked at the car now my
best friend best friend got knocked up
by a carnie she didn't work at the
carnival I think he was 40 and she [ __ ]
you Joe Dirt well you thought I'd do
that of teaching to make the road the
ultimate redneck bro it was perfect
he better in a carnival and for the day
took her back at the corner I see that
I've had up but I never liked a lot of
hot though even when I never I never
liked a lot of meat though yeah I don't
like I liked more bun than
I love the Dodger dogs I've had the
Dodger dog but we're going to try that
dog that better I never go to Arizona
with my restaurant I think that is
Cooper had a restaurant with the big
hurt the big the unit the big the big
unit that are ready Randy what's it
called Alice Cooper and him right yeah
mean collab they call the hot like the
Big Unit the Big Unit what's up
hope you wait there I didn't eat there
brother you get to go there but I will
[ __ ] up a chili dog at the Arlington
baseball man oh you said they're big
I'll eat something but you almost died
there after hear that big-ass [ __ ]
takes to raise your helmet full of
potato tots what else risk it oh cheese
sour cream it was actually really good
well the meal itself had a big-ass vegan
chili dog with being cheesy
nobody's Carly got caught
what's up fool upcoming shows this
Friday October 12 a bit the Majestic
Theatre in Dallas this Saturday are
being Houston at the Cullen Performing
Arts Center at the University of Houston
campus October 18 through 21st as a
temper improv Seattle Washington October
26 at the Moore theater Reno Nevada
October 27 at the Silver Legacy Casino
home of the world's famous big potato
buffet that's what I keep in Denver
Colorado New Year's Eve baby December
31st at Paramount Theater I'm coming
there on the summer 30 if there's
anybody there would look with a
collectible you know I'm a dissonant
this is a shop yeah if you know any
dispensaries in the Denver area hit us
up because like dispensaries with like a
good social media following and good
following you could partner with to do
some promotion be home you have reached
the voicemail box of three two what's up
fool everybody's [ __ ] it is we brought
everybody fool yeah well yeah because
the mid middle of October squeezy
yeah middle of October is when all the
networks are done buying shows they run
out of money like they have a certain
amount of budget and then they say yes
to what they're gonna say yes to and
they're done by mid-october and then
everybody starts writing the pilot
scripts and then January they know
whether it's gonna be shot as a pilot or
not and then if it's shot as a pilot in
airs then or gets evaluated as a pilot
then in about May you know if you're
gonna get a show for the fall by be yeah
so basically a year in preparation much
yeah cuz we started what in May I think
meeting with people Wow so would take
about a year so yeah but we met with
them it was good the meeting
BC we are the way out of the meeting up
today we ran into Carroll Pooky Pooky
Johnson cookie Wigington rookie Whittle
will you will you boogie man a fight
night Oh chuckles I mean he died the day
Becky was there bro big shot it may be
like everything yeah insecure broad city
a lot of stuff parts of Riggs yeah all
they Amy Poehler stuff
although CK shows they beg you the man
and I wouldn't know we're now coming out
a restaurant already took Kevin Hart bro
oh they were all pitching together and
when I wear sweats oh it was gonna
happen so I opened up with Kevin Hart we
all you know
oh no you went after him at Netflix yeah
so a Netflix he was there before me do
that for came in with a [ __ ] 2018
Ferrari
oh it was waiting out there in front of
the whole garage and everything they had
waiting it's like telling Netflix if you
don't give you a special someone nothing
about a Ferrari
that's a power I might live drive away
now Heidi I said you should be in the
Mayan brought ago we said a try bro but
about two ugly whoa no they actually in
the Hollywood way they said his agent
said well these are the people who had
they've brought on the show so far and
they're all pretty boys with like five
o'clock shadow you know and guns showing
outside of their leather leather vest
there's guns
yeah so we're ready to give her hard and
he's had a meeting so I opened up for
him tell everybody about you sure chef
everybody see that my shirt this way
$25 $25 people to some outside of you
for dirty yeah Alex DeLarge designed it
and we're gonna have them up online this
afternoon this evening as soon as we get
done with all our stuff today yeah
covered Arab people and I want me at
some of the live shows but not in Texas
you got shows coming up with me oh yeah
this Sunday when we get back I'm gonna
be with Flaco and Rizzo at Durer Wolf's
off a 72 north fair oaks in Pasadena
so yeah that'll be like 9:00 p.m. and
then people is jokes November 13th keep
an eye on that house Flaco he's cool
I see the wouldn't see him seem like
what I'm not saying he was not pretty
he's not a pretty boy like these guys
like there's pretty boys and then there
are other people who terrible did
Rodrigo and their Mario Lopez okay and
everyone else is in between no Matt sit
man rest in peace Flaco half man are you
doing a short San Francisco anytime soon
yes I'm gonna be at the Warfield theater
on November 2nd November 2nd the day
after the Raider game that will be a
Hector Munoz he's gonna be venom and I'm
gonna be spider-man bad blood we make
280 million dollar because I helped
promote it
I'm coming I was taking more venom to
bro carnage
I'm gonna be carnage I saw that when we
don't be lettin si everybody bro I'm
gonna be carnage I saw that bro look out
for me any shoulder Los Angeles yes bro
Ontario California
December 27th through the 29th yeah the
last weekend of December not including
New Year's Eve because every newsie but
also you're doing a short set
fundraiser show for stand up for pits on
November 11 that is Hollywood at the
Avalon I don't know if tickets are on
sale but you can go to stand up for pits
org and that's Rebecca quarry we had her
on the podcast talking about pit bulls
and stuff and she did put seats shows
together bilborough's been on a lot of
the shows a lot of other comedians hell
bro
so I'm Felipe's doing well I think
you're doing one of the shows because
you get into town that day so you're not
going both their two shows that night
but it goes to a good cause
pitbull rescue it that's what I did I
say that yeah okay so before doing the
tiger belly podcast with Bobbie Lee and
his girlfriend it was at his house
metaphor he bought an apartment in 12
years ago when they were up first
Hollywood look I really yeah
pry but they're matter that kinda 90s
you said yeah when I met 12 years ago
2006 there you go
what a condo down there happy only messy
with name is a dog also oh man one of
those old a little bunnies that we
adopted it really adopted but we were
helping them we sponsored and we
sponsored his surgery because he had a
better life at the way little starlight
did it a little rabbit came in all beat
up bro I think they think a dog bit its
back leg
yeah just like deteriorated amputated
the amputated and fix them up bro and
then this will got bad like they picked
his leg and and then he was good enough
to get neutered and I think they who
girls really ought to get him neutered
or did you hang it out with a cat or a
dog
yeah it'll chill I hope yeah only three
legs bro seven about is food you got a
kickstand
that's tripod they live happy lives but
yeah he he had some other internal
issues they don't know what it was they
couldn't find anything yeah so how long
do bunnies usually last a little bit
there's some cats me lasting 30 years
dude I think I had in my cat for like 17
years I think I found her when she was
four weeks old she was abandoned
Evangeline Portal names I didn't used to
be a porn anyway yo Evangeline was a
religious name I know about that for you
you are all bad weird the way the birch
was you know farted it was me and they
just started busting up like five people
just like I usually hold everything do a
lot of Mexicans from Puebla and Guerrero
and their faith in Nyack Wow all the
early latinos migrated to California
Texas or New York when I lived in New
York there were no there was one guy
from Mexico these guys were all in the
kitchens that I met there was one guy I
met from Mexico the rest of them were
Dominican Puerto Rican Cuban and
Colombian no Mexicans at all and then
now it's a lot over there we hope that
he's gonna come to Europe Anton Olson
but it might be a little small tour
first we're hoping next year or the year
after I'd love to do something over
there even if it's not a moneymaker for
you know just building the audience to
go with it man we're at the Apple they
took Toby
yeah you did you time you talked to him
yeah I talked to him he said he wasn't
sweating it but he might be the Kramer
episode who came up to me bro and I saw
the [ __ ] to copy hi him
I'll tell that full state yo down take
this joint in my mouth I got a Jordan my
mouth
I'm about to bust to spit at you catch
it he told him he came up to us before
like I was a god minutes before you know
me brought tears they preach again and
clear I'm out
yeah but like when I was sitting down at
that spot remember in front of that
screen right by the gate he came up and
then he took off and Felipe stayed there
no Filippo to go get something to drink
and came back and when he came back from
the big shark gave me an edible and this
one was open in an edible and this fool
comes up with like little sweat on his
nose between his eyes and he had two
port authorities and they look serious
and my whole thing was like did they
sniff him over there at the gate and
then they zero them down in the cameras
all wrong and this was I don't know dog
[ __ ] they're gonna give this with a
edible
[ __ ] that I went over there and I
[ __ ] peel the sticker off the edible
and then [ __ ] throw away the little
wrapper I was like [ __ ] that dude I just
got jell-o's dog and uh you know they
took him but then they like took him to
the other side to cut them suffer
Haitian we here baked cod El Chapo and
then they put him in handcuffs and they
walked him out you didn't record that
video it didn't record no bro oh and
then uh so yeah he took off but then he
told us that they busted him that the
first time and then they let him go
there all right whatever they had to
process him yeah and then I guess the
bosses called him know hey you got a
go-getter
we're gonna process this and cuz I guess
who showed him his paperwork that he you
know he smokes and it's all legal and
they went back there and he just hit him
the sign [ __ ] he says they let him go on
an hour and a half and they redid it and
there's all a man we hate to do this but
they told us to do it so and then I
guess the another guy came in when he
was sitting there and they busted this
guy for a grinder I'm a fool I had a
great black know he's a white dude he's
off he's on my food I had a grinder he's
all yeah but they didn't find your
[Laughter]
what's the name Keith Manson what'd you
get busted for some [ __ ] that's what
drove in guys Carl Carl I was outside
nobody move
yeah so yeah they got busted Toby other
[ __ ] delayed it's like it was funny
because I was telling that's what I was
trying to tell Tom Segura that the
airport is over Atlanta and sovereign
land it's there are the real laws yeah
it's I mean they don't have a court
system there but their laws they're
gonna believe what they say when you go
to court to the regular court of course
and they're part of the Department of
Homeland Security Wow God it has more
leverage when they want it to have it
you know Peter Hagen Bill Blair will be
here on Monday or at least on the air
yes at Waffle mangoes those are also
called champagne mangoes from the
Philippines those are my favorite
they're out of season and that's what
they use for mango and sticky rice I'm a
sticky rice I don't know
that guy just brought it up but stick it
was good my favorite answer sticky rice
whatever put brought with real broke
dark
rice yeah we have that yes that's the
forbidden rice I think that they made it
with it's forbidden you've never had it
no cuz it's forbidden
I saw crazy rich Asians telling you bro
goes he is a [ __ ] wasn't name is so
funny bro but we can
oh he's hilarious in a different totally
different way than rich - right but the
rich of the crazy rich Asians yeah he's
rich but the American stands by American
standards but not rich like don't wanna
[ __ ] hear it but like it's funny but
they their seed they let the ghetto
Chinese dudes of the but the rich do but
they're like they are getting rich
because they like their clothes are off
just too flashy and like it's gaudy it's
yohoney like other food came in plastic
bag like this yeah they're [ __ ]
eating your dog
yeah like tight pants like Peggy she was
dressed almost like Peggy Bundy almost
with the flashy top you know it's
[ __ ] funny man I can't lead also
wasn't able to forgive me oh yank buddy
yeah he's good I'll do my own movie
birds you know better crazy-ass baskets
crazy Richard Mascis well this was
talking about right here talking about
food okay somebody waking me up
Singapore's so Bjork
so what you won't would you dad say
about your back so what the devil's
never had back problems oh I don't get
it could a couch he has he being at all
know like he's fit yeah he's fit yes
yeah but he's never had any back
problems he's all what the [ __ ] you
don't do [ __ ] and you get [ __ ] hurt
[Laughter]
yeah do we know that we have another
meaning to the universe
no I'm surprisingly not nervous this
morning I wasn't nervous I just was
running behind which I don't like Isaac
good rotc Oh barks maybe she's I know
they shoot Oh a little sniper oh yeah
well that's like air rifles but I think
you have to get like a hundred on the
test - can't miss any so he's taking it
two times three times and he gets like
ninety every time but they don't let you
know what you missed
yeah so it's hard to go back and try to
prepare you know what I mean can bring a
phone with you know on the computer and
I think it's good and but it's like it's
not you know it's about safety the whole
test is about safety and all that so you
know they're all killing someone you
know but he's not the only one not
passing like it's hard she's hard to get
a hundred to get a hundred on stuff
especially for somebody like Ike who's
not a good test taker in the first place
which I know we're trying out while I'm
fighting to get a haircut like that the
last manic gets all the good ones go
there six no value all the hipper ones
with younger people work in there so we
ended up going to this lady in your
grandma or what China yeah eject of your
hair versus Alice Ellie's one of those
places - to a donut shop that everybody
hangs out there just to play keno but do
they buy donuts yeah if you could over
here if you google the hair place
there's a picture of bundles say sitting
in the window like that's one of the
features it says right next to the
mannequin done what happened
so one of the places bro where the dad
gets that same haircut of the Sun yeah
man honey what you hear what kind of
hair cool you want just like my daddy
ugly they do like they'll reduce hair
cut this short and shorter
commando or come on down yeah this guy
had a zero
Oh your whole hair cuts your hair Burt
we call them birds because I haircut bro
we're like these honey no combs
and no [ __ ] shampoo at this place it
sucks because a lot of people that cut
the hair the same it's cool if everybody
had the same kind of head but they don't
go now look [ __ ] wreck dude like my
head you gotta cut it right [ __ ]
[ __ ] applause she's putting Eisen here
and I dropped my phone and they would
Eve know that Oh bad vision the floor
no next to it like when he went to pick
it up inside I thought he was joking
I don't get psoriasis is demo their
seats that [ __ ] Bible should have a
cigarette degenerate cigarettes for
blood but I was in there googling
frantically like no to see what else was
open and what people's reviews for this
place I was worried and I was like oh my
son is about to get jacked up I was
worried cuz he had a picture of some
dude with like a pompadour sort of thing
he wanted you know and I was like this
woman's not gonna be able to give him
that haircut but she did a good job and
it was $17 you gotta communicate it
right to the people I remember a [ __ ]
barber told me what I saw a man next
time tell me that the beginning of the
haircut Amaro okay do whatever cut it
off but the whole I like dudes coming
bro everybody came into her dirty ass
pants bro I think you from war and they
all came for this you need mechanics bro
Labor's those fools us whether a black
like Jack crazy rich Indians ooze broken
crazy rich in this book there's a Thai
restaurant open next door
but the but the corner shop next door
and one of the tonal sounds every step
of sandwich bro oh yeah they make deli
sandwiches Big Daddy sandwiches and the
breakfast danishes but the main thing
there bro is lotto takers in ketover
know why people buy so many a lot of
tickets at that place maybe there been
past winners there yeah
it's hot funky keelaurow
but that's good I'm $17 yeah 17 go
dollars is good because he used he goes
with his stepmom she takes something
like Floyd's barbershop and those chains
you know like Rudy's 30 bucks they will
[ __ ] jack up your hair and I got a
jacked up haircut from there one time
and it's and it's like 30 $35 the rest
but I got a haircut one time and this
one babe woman made bangs and and I was
like the bangs were a little crooked and
I was like I don't know if I like and
then she went that's a start and I was
like it's a start like this is my
[ __ ] hair later I was so sad worries
it's gonna Jack the parodies man no I
never gave Isaac a bowl cut either but
you used to say that the way I cut it
cuz I wasn't very good with the Clippers
but you used to say that his hair look
like I bid it all choppy and part did he
pump it up then it looks good I didn't
it look good yeah it's a super big
pompadour he just wanted it to be it's
like all shaved on the side you're like
Brian Setzer laughs no no some of the
baseball players have it like it's all
shaved and then there's like longer hair
be horrendous and it's kind of like
swept back so it's not a pompadour but
it is a little higher so I don't know
he's really into his hair right now we
have arguments about it every morning
like like a mother knows that place man
needed to hire somebody to sweep nobody
I wouldn't laugh and put a saw bad deed
go judo bro
I picked it up and say hey did somebody
drop this just so they could bring it
off sorry but that place is like up it's
funny man like you know how you go to
like you be living like in a
neighborhood they have a lot of barns
or the head this was a Ralph's market or
a lot of h-e-bs or whatever type our
supermarket there in your neighborhood
but just a lot of them you want to know
which one is the one you're gonna go to
always because you know which one is bad
already
oh we can't go to that one bro I only go
there for milk that's ghetto Vaughn's
you know it's like look even try bad man
this Kroger back in Ohio where I used to
miss miss no it's Ralph's product but
Kroger is in all of Ohio there's no
Ralph's there so but my friend still
works there after all these years he's
been cutting meat for years and he still
works there those hominy and SMO and
drinks are for tea every day just 140
that's his day every day
but he they call it killer Kroger that's
the Kroger that he works at his killer
Kroger because it's so good oh and
they've been for Kroger they should be
on a 24-hour Kmart in Sacramento or just
a Kmart by Sacramento and they were like
in a ghetto outside right
basically I bought a [ __ ] ticket KKK
more KKK marcuzzo that red next triple
Kmart
that was by that ghetto ass that Kmart
we put we totally passed by one time
when you and I took the bus to go get up
forget to the medicinal shop
we ran into a bail bondsman Oh in
Sacramento
yeah yeah [ __ ] bail bondsman ready to
capture somebody huh they were on their
way
oh there it is broken key Kmart in the
hood the Piggly Wiggly other dirty a
store too high that the super a of the
hood I thought we went to a Piggly
Wiggly was on the way from Nashville to
Huntsville
we're on a hog film sure to make up man
this [ __ ] got a podcast now
Oh long [ __ ] let's see what it is having
a Halloween show right you know what no
I think this is a before Halloween Iran
it's the Monday it's the 30th I think or
the 29th can you say where is it no what
time or what they and is it at
harvelle's shut up to Jacob Garcia yeah
yeah man the gathered rouse are our
podcast cartoons Mario right Mario Mario
Christian I saw that Megaman was online
doing a story live from Instagram
nothing my room Chile I thought this was
talking about so I saw he was chatting
was Mario and I found out that I'm Marty
Moreno is gonna have a a Halloween party
on October 22nd Monday night and our
veils if anybody vailable that they
harvelle's
Long Beach October 22nd Marty Moreno and
hooter are gonna have the Halloween
extravaganza and they're gonna give out
baskin-robbins pools of Cote Monday
night Monday night and you're coming
back into town from Tampa a mega man is
gonna be there he's gonna be a
broadcasting helping out my team but
this is the funny part for Mario from
Atlanta the guy who draws us that fools
gonna feel it's gonna spend the night at
Megabass house bunk buddies with bunk
buddies bro never met the [ __ ]
you don't know how that Megabass screams
at night nice
he farts too much you're right Alex I
didn't like your yo-yo
I totally be called cooler and son or
more or you know why I lost our podcast
never been a better title yeah you know
what lasts a podcast would have been a
better name
okay but hey I came up with what some
food I know came over yeah man I thought
I could have been you know my recipe
well so MC poncho brother footer that
fool [ __ ] took on her his carbons bro
he can't cover them more on a little
dance basically you're gonna be able to
watch me dance whoo he's on that man
bothering nobody but a lot of fools why
they want a job but they don't know
they're here now but you don't know
they're bagging on him yeah but some of
that [ __ ] was harsh
from what I remember I don't remember
word for word but it's like I think I
said now we're gonna be troubled Ethan
you're going to be I wanted to be John
Redcorn and Nancy though that's because
she might be it's Halloween you don't
have to have a perfect costume to be
autistic let's be perfect I'm see poncho
don't have a beard he's good you have to
get your designed facial hair straighten
your hair or do two braids your hair is
too short for the to bring it a little
hat harmful rings
if he was a mustache though dog yeah but
I can't do that dance but both my knees
what is their dance when he went down
like that he's gonna step so shots of DJ
well doesn't let that he was bugging dog
rescuer disco bells are live radio show
a lot of those fools that are that age
do that [ __ ] yeah it's like that cholo
boogie I don't know my brain would call
the best bull you would ever saw where
as well now kudos Tito's crew sceeto is
at that party and blood in blood out and
he sees a little hard-ass cholita and he
started to book it to her bro
to the side that's a mean little cholo
site many bloody bloody
oh yeah he goes I whatever rages grabs
her and he's having sex with her the car
they've seen [ __ ] that yeah if you
mean you know Mexican people like
Hispanic people like there's people that
even like they've watched that movie
like 50 to 100 times that would be in
Spanish with subtitles
the regular one that's just funny
because I like black people will just
hoop on you and just I won't whoopin
your ass white people just going to get
off my sister but best kids will always
make your ass beat you for the effort
it's a total tease I don't know T that
we don't like that she lovely up Ayyappa
and then that will go save me broke his
back at a height and a [ __ ] fire
higher bro made up a heroin addict so I
would just stayed in that car dog [ __ ]
that
hell yeah but yeah man they swooped up
on that foot but then it got those holes
back nasty to go I like the large tire
by that up it was Halloween facial pain
is bro for Halloween
please be yeah we're at Alex he does do
it that's why I asked him to design that
he does do it by hand also are people's
faces on the festival dear little mark
those festivals they have people to do
Facebook yeah I know what time either
totally to be spider-man and she just
put a spider in his forehead
yeah by southern orthophoto do bro I
think Isis shouldn't do facial face
painting if they don't know that the
American culture yeah American kosher
cabrona like like each other be cheap I
wanna be Captain America and then she
just pins your whole flight at the whole
thing America
lagging that's it captain but I tell you
about Isaac's dad when he was a kid he
got a face painting and he wanted to
look like kiss
he asked for kiss and she just wrote
kiss but if you just wanted this
she wrote kiss on the side of his face
[Laughter]
Saruman
let's get back to that fur coat yeah
that guy Mario drew me it was a cute
little photo but it was a little blonde
girl and I wasn't your regular sweater
that was Friday's outfit doesn't know
how to draw for a coach it wasn't even
for you it's just like a ski jacket kind
of thing puffy jacket Northlands I
called it my fur Jack I've had to pay
blood and blood out or American me I'll
just stay there like what's your blood
in blood out because that's just funny
sorry we have no authority yeah it's a
little bit of camp to it yeah
American means so deep what so fool
paint my face to look like Gary Coleman
yeah man that she was pretty yea by yea
by yea by yea by yea swooped on that
fool turns by himself on a little
hillside on Mac and on his little
Hyneman that's funny man because you can
actually get that that song by Charles
is Charlie Gambino this is America and
it put the same song to Guru Seto when
he's picking about that chick doing the
same there this is American me was so
foolish oh come on door wolf there wolf
something like underground little also
I'm going to be at the Warfield theatre
on November the 2nd and on San Diego and
November 1st I'll be at the Raiders
49ers game in San Francisco in San
Francisco
and hopefully Levi Levi is that Levi's
stadium I think that the the Raiders and
a 49er will be battling for worst record
of the NFL Battle of the bay bro are
they doing badly to the Niners yes
weapons with AIDS bro
it's unfortunate what happened next yeah
[ __ ] up the Yankees and the Yankees
got [ __ ] up awful how about those
Dodgers duh
jairs getting ready to make some cheese
out of Milwaukee man I thought I just
loved watching like Braves fans get
their hearts broken he's up they're
gonna come back with a tomahawk chop and
get out of here white lady bro holding a
Bible grow through the gay come on later
helps like like Gaza to pick you without
us a man and bobbling got nothing and be
with baseball my and put that bang away
lady
I feel the breath that I make you man
mine cuz they just weren't brave enough
man ready for what wrap it up were so
cool we didn't have a guest today we're
just the three of us today people that's
it yeah you guys have a wonderful
weekend keep shining huh that's right
man we're back tobe with us all all with
us who the [ __ ] is Johnny Rock you will
be there with us this weekend too what
have you lost
would you have please please shut up to
search or show our Mitch banks what's up
Mitch 240 is si el half Mexican dude
Mitch banks here from China belly we'll
take your homeboy go Lakers Johnny
handsome I really like Niagara back well
this time we stayed in I am NOT
suffering like Western laughter we're
suffering what did you eat anything in
that fair the Greek sausage we saw
George :
Pinsky hey George yeah no dress code at
the Balboa theater no just go bro
I mean don't wear anything crazy make
sure you're fully clothed
what's up fool I said we got to do a
pitch me good luck go do a pitch meeting
with CBS thank you guys for listening